and now Great Moments in unintended
Consequences part one tree decree the
year 2019 the problem Mexico needs trees
the solution the sewing life project a
3.4 billion dollar program that pays
Farmers to plant fruit and Timber trees
on Barren land not only will this help
spruce up the environment but it will
fight poverty and inequality by paying
the farmers to maintain the new trees
sounds like a great idea with the best
of intentions what could possibly go
wrong it turns out poor Farmers need
money and since standing trees didn't
qualify for the program the system
incentivized Farmers to cut down mature
trees to make way for new ones in one
Village two-thirds of the program's
participants chopped down forests to get
that cash one study found the program
caused the deforestation of more than
280 square miles but you know what they
say about the best laid plants
part two take care the year 1998 the
problem well technically this was a
research study but private daycare
centers in Israel are tired of parents
arriving late the solution find tardy
parents a small fee for every Lake
pickup sounds like a great idea with the
best of intentions what could possibly
go wrong it turns out money isn't the
only incentive and a fine is just a
price to the surprise of the researchers
later Rivals more than doubled the
penalty it seemed allowed parents to
ease their conscience the shameful
apology that once burdened them shifted
to a simpler legitimate cash transaction
when they were happy to pay because
honestly ask any new parent what they
wouldn't pay for an extra 10 minutes of
free time
part three loophole lunch the year 1896
the problem alcohol is ruining the moral
fiber of New York the solution the rains
law a bevy of rules that made it harder
to open or operate shrinking
establishments including a ban on the
sale of alcohol on Sundays except for
hotel and lodging houses that serve
drinks with complimentary meals I mean
wealthy New Yorkers tend to dine out at
ritzy hotels when their servants have
the day off so no need to ruffle their
Rich upstanding virtuous feathers it's
those poor people that are ruining
everything so yeah Stick it to them
sounds like a terrible idea with
puritanical intentions what could
possibly go wrong it turns out people
like drinking even on Sundays the ban
was wildly unpopular almost immediately
rains law hotels were born basements and
attics were converted into barely
furnished rooms and Proprietors made
deals with neighboring lodging houses in
Brooklyn the number of registered hotels
went from 13 to 800 after six months
prostitutes and unmarried couples found
the new rooms especially convenient to
fulfill the Law's food requirement bar
staff invented the rain sandwich an easy
simple meal that would be served with a
patrons drink but not consumed the
frequently inedible sandwich would be
whisked away in seconds and quickly
paired with the next order it was not
uncommon for the same sandwich to be
reused for weeks yum food for naught
Great Moments in unintended consequences
good intentions bad results do you know
a great moment in unintended
consequences put it in the comments we
might steal it I mean borrow it I mean
yeah you know you know what I mean